all right
nick nick uh where'd you grow up where
are you from originally
i'm from southern california uh vista
in san diego county is where i grew up
uh most of my adolescence what was your
childhood like
my childhood was a pretty extreme
black and white mix between poverty
and i would say stability and privilege
you know i grew up with my my mom and my
dad
uh in a pretty stable home
up into a certain point which my parents
parents addiction took the better of
them and uh
poverty became a pretty regular thing
i'm moving
a lot so going from vista to temecula to
san marcos
to san diego every month every year
a couple times a year living in cars
living in storage units
living in strangers houses you recall
one time coming home to a house that uh
i had woken up in and went left to
school
from uh when i came home walked in the
door there was an empty house with a
different family and
uh as a you know an eight-year-old
that's kind of shocking
um and they progressed from there uh
until at some point my my parent that i
was with my mother at that time
realized that her addiction was getting
a little too bad that she needed to turn
us over to my dad
so i would say about the age of
13 me and one of my
sisters returned to live with my father
in vista he had a girlfriend
she had a stable job he had a stable job
so
uh very quickly went from that kind of
rollercoaster life
of poverty and uncertainty to
um having the same address the same
phone number
um on the same friends for for the rest
of our our childhood so i adapted pretty
well to that
i was a really shy kid i didn't talk a
lot
i was always kind of a quiet observer
especially kind of going through
you know what i did as a child
i never really experienced a lot of uh
heavy heart abuse sexual otherwise but
um you know i kind of witnessed things
um and i was i was kind of afforded the
opportunity to learn from
from my environment you know that i
didn't have to endure things i didn't
have to participate in
in certain things um did you have goals
as a kid
this is really funny goals um
i i did i knew that i wanted to
quote be successful to a certain degree
um at that time i think it was
uh money family health
um and and i experienced this kind of
this overwhelming feeling of uh
accomplishment and or
ability i knew that i could be a
a priest an astronaut
the president or a scientist i knew that
i could do any one of those things as a
kid if i
if i applied myself and i would be happy
but i wasn't sure i wasn't sure what i
was going to do until
i got my first job at 17
and that was in a retirement home
i got exposed to nursing and medical
work and i became
a certified nurse aide at 19.
i worked that type of work for about
four or five years and i and i really
enjoyed it and i started to pursue
a career in nursing college um
you know and and growing up as a kid
with a
parent that was an addict and a parent
that was a user
drugs were never taboo
really my parents and my family
acted like my friends sometimes more so
than my parents and so
it was never an issue coming home wasted
or calling the parent dad or mom to come
pick me up if i was too drunk or i'd
taken too much acid or
or anything uh and so i practiced that
way
living in indulgence uh
what do they say function with some
functionality for a number of years
you know from i would say 14 when i
began using marijuana and alcohol to
escape my reality
[Music]
all the way up until i think i was 20 20
years old
when i discovered opiates and all their
glory
that's when i really gave my life away
to a substance
my drug of choice was heroin
and other opiates very quickly i went
from a functioning addict who would be
able to go
to work you know nine to five monday
through friday party and drink on the
weekends
to somebody who had to use every day
all day before work after work during
work
um i remember the first time that i that
i tried that drug um
the first time i tried it i wasn't
really interested i didn't really know
anybody who did it it was very
kind of taboo at that time
but i that i acquired some uh it was a
sunday night
and if i could go back to that night i
would slap the [ __ ] out of myself
i would i would slap the [ __ ] on myself
for for picking up such a
a crazy crazy habit because
i instantly i i resigned myself to
become
uh this new identity this new heroine
nick this new heroine chic that like was
like desperado heroin nick that i
thought was so cool you know um
i i didn't go to work the next day or
the day after that or the day after that
uh by friday uh
my partner came home and she said you
know you haven't been to work all week
what's going on you know
and that's when i when i showed her um
you know what i had been doing with how
i'd been getting high and it was that
easy for me to just
turn my life over because that that
substance is a
powerful painkiller of many types
emotional spiritual
boredom so um you know i
i gave my life away very quickly to
that realm and suffered the consequences
very quickly
you know after
four or five years i was on the streets
uh dereliction
um unemployable not knowing how to be
human i didn't know
you know how to look people in the eye i
didn't know how to
to be honest i would lie to people about
you know the color of my
shirt because lying had just become such
a
regular way of life to survive you know
it was always a con
i was like a con man out there um you
know but at some point i got
i got uh arrested
and that was good that was really good
for me i was arrested
uh in a blackout and the blackout
continued for
i would say anywhere from four to
ten days in the gel system
um how that's possible i don't know i am
lucky i didn't die but i had ingested
such a
high number of um benzodiazepines that i
i was seriously fading in and out of
consciousness
in and out of a blackout for like i said
four to ten days in the gel system where
i was able to to kick my habit um
and at 25 you know i gave myself a
second
chance at life uh i decided to go back
to school and pursue
working as a nurse working in that field
helping people
i'm a pacifist i
am not a violent person very easy going
and
i like to see myself in a healer's role
and it's a great role for me because i
can hide from myself i can hide from all
my problems
when i'm focused on yours and i can help
people heal
and i've met some amazing people doing
that um
and uh it's a journey that i'm still
working on today
uh you know at say
four years into that journey working
part-time going to school part-time
around the time i was 30 one of my
parents
became critically ill he had been
chronically ill
terminally ill for a number of years
but he had turned around his habits and
his lifestyles and and he was able then
to gain
a number of extra years of life so that
was great um
but being a medical background person
you know i i
quickly jumped in to help my dad in his
days in hospice i
i helped him six days a week 24 hours a
day
and i worked with him and i tried to
keep him healthy and i tried to keep
moving and i tried to keep him engaged
in life
but the man was suffering greatly
greatly
um and uh
you know he he ended up losing his
battle with his chronic disease
and and during that process
i had definitely fallen off the horse
the sobriety horse had fallen off and
relapsed on
alcohol opioids and and other substances
a couple months into the hospice care
for my dad working
you know living with my dad six days a
week
24 hours a day dealing with that family
dynamic
uh nine aunts 150 cousins
everyone wanting to help everybody
wanting to contribute
people fighting over
diets and things like that it was a
nutritional
diagnosis he lacked the
ability to process nutrients and so he
was always hungry
oh he's always hungry and in the in the
hispanic culture that i grew up in on my
dad's side
providing food to the man
to the man to the family is like a huge
part of
um love and connection um
so really fighting to to give him what
he wanted even though it was killing him
every day
so that was that was tough but uh yeah
um you know i i fell off my my my high
horse and
i moved back home as i
i kind of divulged that indeed i had um
relapsed
on opiates alcohol and everything else
and
i spent a little bit of time struggling
and i and i eventually got clean
again
i got clean in december um
december 7th 2019
uh which is three days before my dad's
birthday at december 10th
um and i got to spend the last of his
days with him
clean and sober and
he passed away in january
um which i stayed sober through yeah so
i i did that um with with the
connection of loved ones and friends um
you know but that kind of you know leads
me up to today
um a couple years later post pandemic um
i've i've kind of been in and out of
of sobriety recovery kind of doing
very well and excelling
like any addict who puts all that
effort from my addiction into
productive productivity going to school
working a job building a relationship
family
career and i'm going kind of back and
forth you know
at this point in time i came down
here to to la i'm kind of on this
around the united states skid row
bottoms
tour i visited quite a few cities
this year and last year and i'm
gravitating towards some very dubious
areas
[Music]
and there's some really amazing people
there's some really [ __ ] scary people
and there's uh just some really cool
sights so
i made my way to lla i've never lived
here i always said that san diego had
all the best parts of la and none of the
bad parts
but uh i don't really think that can
hold this mud anymore i mean
i think i'd like to relocate here and
check it out a little bit more
but um what is it about
you know because you you clearly
understand how being clean and
living a productive life is probably a
good thing for you
yet you keep getting pulled back
what do you think is is the attraction
uh definitely the lack of responsibility
and at this point i'm living in a car
that hasn't been financed it's leased
and the lien holder has been paid in six
weeks
so um that's a real [ __ ] lack of
responsibility there
and that's very um intoxicating and very
alluring
sounds insane and it is um
but uh there's there's real
a real sense of freedom
and a real sense of uh
like an eternal childhood that um you
know
maybe i'm longing for now because i
wanted to grow up so fast when i was
when i was younger um but i
i don't doubt that i'll find my way back
you know i'm
again like a a healer type a peaceful
person and
my disease always takes me to a point
where my next question is
do i pick up um a gun or do i check into
rehab
and i'm checking to rehab every time how
old are you
32 32. yeah
no kids no kids no i don't have any kids
um i have a lot of dogs those are my my
kids
um and uh i think that's definitely
played a huge [ __ ] role in
in my journey because um
i would like to think if i had kids that
oh hey i would pull back and tighten up
like my dad did
you know my mom was definitely an addict
um definitely needed some some heavy
intervention
to recover her life my father not so
much
the textbook addict or alcoholic was
able to
pull back and and stop uh partying
when he had kids when the time came to
be a family man a responsible man
so i don't know how uh
i would i would fit in that role you
know um
i'm i think i've been a little bit too
selfish over the years
um when it comes to
to stepping into that role i will i will
say though
when he passed away i
i began dating
somebody who had a kid and very quickly
very ironically i went from
grieving a father who had just died to
being a father figure in a relationship
with a very damaged person who
needed a lot of recovery themselves and
that was quite a a roll switch for me
almost like a high itself
where do you see your life going now
um i mean you your next step is losing
the car potentially oh yeah and then
being homeless
and you're attracted to la which
probably would take you to skid row
yeah then that's not going to be good
for me i've got
um some pretty serious business that
i've got to attend to in northern
california
coming up here
some some property business that
needs to be taken care of before it
turns into legal
problems um so i will be
as i'm even though i'm spending a lot of
time here in la i am supposed to be
heading towards northern california uh
to take care of some stuff um
so at that point god it's going to be
like a real rude awakening
there's going to be a lot of
responsibility a lot of stepping up to
the plate
calling people making decisions tough
decisions
showing up and just [ __ ] showing up
participating and um being a grown-up
being a grown-up you know so hey that
might be a good stepping stone to
transition into just a little
detox or something do you think that
having the parents that you did
maybe somehow kept you from
maturing as a normal child would
and and you're kind of still
being a child at 32.
wow well you know if i would
if they were here right now they could
kind of look at me
and nod or wink they would probably
agree with that statement based off of
my behavior
um but
it's easy to judge an addict and say oh
you're just you're just screwing up and
i understand that addiction is much more
complicated than that
but as an outsider i look at like oh my
god you just you just need to
man up and take some responsibility and
do the right thing and
i know it's not as simple as that yeah
no definitely not there's
they say it's easier to get sober than
it is to stay sober
um
i think that
you know i was allotted enough
freedom then to
to find out really um what i could
handle
uh like
friendship wise personal relationships
sex
um drugs alcohol
finances money you know they they
allotted me enough
freedom and and room to kind of
go out and kind of with their
supervision roughly
figure out like what was gonna
work or what was a good way for me and
and to be honest with you
i haven't figured [ __ ] out yet you know
or if i do uh it gets mundane and boring
very fast
and
[Music]
i i don't know what the the
self-sabotage
element is to it but um yeah i
i can say that i'm i'm very very lucky
to have
uh the family that i do that's
that surrounds me that still talks to me
an unbelievable amount of
love and forgiveness for this addict who
on a regular basis um
shows up to [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] up uh
screw people over
and um you know nothing but love
uh and and
with that you know i'm also uh
learning and growing in in my personal
relationships
uh one in particular um with my fiancee
who
a very interesting dynamic meeting
in sobriety meeting in rehab
[Music]
you know spending a number of years
together sober
and and walking that walk and now here
uh at
the row skid row walking the walk of the
year as well
so um we're learning a lot about each
other we're growing a lot and
um we're definitely having our moments
of
uh well it's obvious that you started
using drugs when you were 14 and it's
obvious
that you started using drugs when you're
16 because here we are
playing the same mind games that we
would be playing at that time
at that age but
a partnership nonetheless a great
partnership that i
am very very
uh dear very i hold it very very dear
and so
um together i know that we're going to
kind of push through this
and and be able to laugh you know one
day
hopefully we wake up on the same page
and that's
where we decide to take a different step
in another direction different direction
that's gonna lead us
away from the vicious cycle
that is addiction very vicious cycle
and um you know help both of us creative
loving individuals um give back
to to humanity to help uh people around
us strangers family friends
help excuse me them
kind of move forward as well you know in
whatever way we can i don't know
i talk about you know nursing and
healthcare and being a healer and a
giver
um but i i i know there's a lot of ego
in that there's a lot of
uh i forgot what the word is you know
there's a lot of
flair and and um
again just a lot of ego and a lot of
image in that role as nick a nurse nikki
healer
you know and i've worked in
jobs that afforded me great finance and
and great uh monetary gains
and options however
at the end of the day if i feel like
my soul is being sucked out of me and
i'm doing nothing but
push paper or something like that
or push people into wheelchairs
and then i'm really not going to be
happy and so i think finding the happy
medium for me
is going to take a little bit more than
[Music]
then just having a a great paying
nursing job you know it's it's really
going to be about me in touch with
uh what's going on in here create
creating something beautiful
um every day whether it's a memory
or a piece of art or piece of uh poetry
you know something that's gonna be
bursting with life
i guess i could say all right nick well
thank you so much for
yeah thank you for
uh for letting me have this opportunity
yeah i wish you and your fiance the best
of luck
yeah thank you thank you very much
you